kirk cousins gets extended mike zimmer
gets extended rick spielman likely will
get extended dalvin cook we thought was
going to get extended it all fell apart
near the end of the virtual off-season
program cook pulled the plug on his
participation and started to make noise
chris that sounded a little bit like he
may hold out a training camp right well
now as we get closer to training camp
this was so bizarre on saturday mike
zimmer talking to reporters in
connection with his new contract he said
that he was told
that dalvin cook will be there for the
start of training camp who told you
dalvin cook told me
then zach hiller dallin cook's agent
issues a statement on saturday saying
that didn't happen i don't know where
that's coming from dalvin never told
mike zimmer he's going to be there for
the start of training camp so then
there's a report from nfl media that
dalvin cook actually told running backs
coach kennedy polamalu that cook was
going to be there polamalu conveyed it
to zimmer and that's the explanation so
cook's going to be there
and then hillary issues another
statement no that didn't happen either
so i don't know what the hell is going
to happen the vikings don't know what's
going to happen tomorrow's the day to
show up for training camp or not if you
don't show up it's 50 000 a day plus
this year under the new cba
you instantly you lose a year of credit
toward free agency you don't have that
buffer anymore right at the early stage
of camp so uh
we're going to find out it's a mess it's
awkward it's confusing and my guess is
zimmer's parade for his new contract got
a little rain on it with this weird
situation that popped up on saturday and
he's probably upset that there's been
this miscommunication that is playing
out publicly yeah well i'm sure he is i
mean no head coach likes that i mean he
made it you know i mean to me from the
outside looking in and we don't know the
facts here i'm just totally speculating
it looks like dalvin cook probably told
his running back coach kennedy palamalu
that hey yeah don't worry coach i'm
going to be there i'm coming i'm coming
in and then he must have told his agent
that you know then his agent sees these
public comments and his agent calls them
and then hey did you say that and you
know they they went into put the ketchup
back into the the ketchup bottle type
mode here i mean that's what it looks
like to me i don't know that but just my
experiences in the nfl and being around
the league that's that's what it leads
me to believe um but this is a weird
situation and i want to say like not
weird i think this is a that's a wrong
word we need to get used to this
situation because every good running
back that gets done with year three of
their career this is what's going to be
done and i can't get mad at them because
their careers are usually over by year
six or seven so they gotta strike now
and dalvin cook is no doubt about it one
of the best running backs in football
and he's making chump change this year
he's gonna make six hundred thousand
dollars
is is kirk cousins really worth like 26
times more than me or whatever the
number is i mean i'm just doing it off
the top of my head it's insane so yeah
that bothers him and let him loan this
is a guy that's tore his acl the second
year in the nfl he realizes how quickly
life can change and he's got to protect
himself so he's got to figure out what
he's going to do here mike i don't know
what do you think the right thing for
him to do here is going forward
actually towards acl non-contact fourth
game of his
yards in each of his career three games
rookie year acl torn
second year it felt like he was always
injured now maybe it was just
you know your body compensates for the
acl hamstring injuries he's had one
great year right and i think he had 1300
rushing yards last year maybe not even
that many
i i just
i i look at
the offense at the vikings run yes under
gary kubiak yeah and i made this point
over the weekend when kubiak was the
offensive coordinator of the denver
broncos they had four different thousand
yard rushers in a five yard and a five
year window right guys like
uh tyrell davis he gets injured olandis
gary has a thousand yards
mike anderson has a thousand yards guys
like ruben drones and tatum bell that
had thousand-yard seasons that offense
is conducive to running back production
at a high level
and at what point did the vikings say
we can't pay you like a top five running
back because our offense helps create
top 10 running backs and we've got
alexander madison we've got what we what
we have budgeted for the position you
know they went through all those years
where they had too much salary cap space
devoted to adrian peterson and he became
the focal point of the offense and as a
result the passing game
couldn't couldn't complement it
sufficiently i i think the vikings have
decided what they're going to pay him
uh and and that's what it is and here's
where we are and dalvin cook's going to
have to make a decision of what he's
going to do is he going to hold out is
he going to show up is he going to play
out this year and wait for the franchise
tag like derek henry did and then sign a
long-term contract this is a tough one
one thing that that
we wrote when derek henry signed and i
think this is true with the exception of
le'veon bell
running backs don't get big contracts
from teams that they didn't already play
for right if you're going to get a big
contract it's going to come from your
team and even bell didn't get close to
what he wanted and as we talked about
earlier the jets got grifted a little
bit by this idea that the ravens were
seriously in play when they weren't
right bell may be the aberration for the
most part you're melvin gordon if you
finish your contract your rookie deal
with the team that drafted you
and you leave as a free agent
they don't have that equity in your name
they don't have all those jerseys in the
stands not that matters this year but
you're not that star central player
that that a a guy who stays there will
be and there's value in that and i think
teams try to try to push that aside you
know dalvin cook a key piece of that
team he became a superstar in minnesota
last year
but
you put in alexander madison and what's
the drop-off chris and i think that's
what the vikings have to consider i
think it's really real i mean i do i
mean you know right like right i
understand what dalvin cook is doing
here and i'm not wouldn't be mad at him
if he did hold out or or opted out or do
anything i wouldn't be uh but i think
all the points you made also are very
real for the vikings first off the
vikings are a team that are very
top-heavy to begin with i mean they are
you know this is one of their issues
they don't have great depth on their
football team because they've drafted
really well and had to pay a lot of
stars and and do things like that you
know but i think the big thing is
you know
you made the right points to me you know
you have a they have a pretty good run
blocking offensive line gary kubiak
knows that shanahan run scheme he knows
that outside inside zone he knows how to
coach it and you mentioned all the guys
that hey think of
he he he didn't even draft aryan foster
he was undrafted and he he led football
in rushing what like two out of the
first four years in football great point
you know great so why he of course is
sitting there going huh we can find
other guys and as you've said many many
times and you just said it madison's
super talented i mean he's he's a you're
right i don't know if there's a lot of a
difference between him and dalvin cook
so i have a hard time thinking that
minnesota is going to bend here and
throw a lot of money at dalvin cook
right now when they're in a little bit
of a semi we're trying to flip the
roster over and get away from the
everson griffin xavier rhodes and trey
wayne's and all that too to where i have
a hard time believing they're going to
throw a big money out of davin cook if
i'm dalvin cook i'm going to training
camp mike and i'm giving what is that
august 16th is that still the day
i'm gonna give it then i'm gonna see how
things go maybe we can get something out
done maybe i can get august three august
three august three is the opt out oh man
yeah yeah here's and this this is the
theory that that i i wrote about this
last night at pft i don't know that this
is going to happen but
he he can show up
on tuesday go through those first few
days which is simply covet 19 testing
right and his agent see you you can't
give a guy a new contract after he's
opted out
but you can there's nothing that
prohibits
conversations hypothetical between his
agent and the vikings saying you know
he's really
he's really concerned about playing this
year
and uh he doesn't think he's being
compensated fairly enough for the risk
that he's taking you throw in his
concerns that he already has as it
relates to his contract you throw on top
of at the risk of playing in a pandemic
and it's not bs i mean it's not all that
difficult to fashion a plausible and
authentic argument that this player who
already has misgivings about suiting up
and playing especially given his injury
history yeah without financial security
beyond this year with only 1.331 million
in salary this year
you need to sweeten it because one of
his options is to say i'll see you next
year i will opt out i will not play and
we'll deal with this situation in 2021.
now it makes it no different for him in
2021 his salary is still 1.331 million
if he opts out but what it does is it
forces the vikings to go forward without
him and that's where alexander madison
becomes an issue he was a third round
pick out of boise state right they used
a third round pick on cook who was a
second round pick after two seasons with
cook that were marred by injury so they
had to have been thinking in 2019
madison may end up being the guy right
cook got it together but if they got a
flip to madison madison averaged more
yards per carry last year than cook
so uh i i i think it's a dangerous game
for zach hiller and dalvin cook to be
playing with the vikings on this because
they're going to slam the door in
someone's face they can't pay everyone
no and it very well could be that if
they start making noise about opting out
in 2020 the vikings say well we'll see
you next year we got alexander madison
we got mike boone and we'll we'll find
other guys too yeah who will do well in
the in the uh gary kubiak rushing attack
yeah no that i think that's that's
exactly right i mean you know yeah mike
boone's got a little talent they do have
a mere abdullah how do they feel about
him do they feel like he could be
healthy and contribute i think those
those two guys alone just boone and
abdullah are names that you go
okay that's the unknown here how do they
feel about them and are they okay with
that you know them being the two and the
three option at the running back
position it's certainly going to hurt
their team if they don't have cook you
know cook madison hey damn you know that
that's how many times last year were we
sitting in there on a sunday going oh
man look at cook hit the hole there and
then we go oh that was madison you know
so it made them a dangerous football
team and there was basically no drop off
you're right madison probably runs with
more power than dalvin cook in a lot of
ways too
but cook is special and this is a team
that wants to run the football and play
defense and then of course run the
bootlegs and play actions off of it so
he's a very valuable commodity between
his talent and the way the offense is
formulated but you're right it's a
dangerous game and they have to be
careful here and you know maybe that's
what happens mike maybe they can just
give him a sweetener to make them feel
better for the year and maybe work on
something long term after the year's
over
and we're big dalvin cook fans we are i
want him to be properly compensated i
wanted to be successful for the vikings
i don't want the vikings to have to pull
the pin and go forward with alexander
madison but the problem is when you
start drawing lines in the sand
you you paint yourself into a corner as
i jam as many potential metaphors as i
can into the same line
but that's that's the real we've seen
that chris we've seen agents get
themselves into a jam because they
huffed and puffed and then when the time
came to blow someone's house in they
didn't know what to do and i'm concerned
based upon what we saw saturday this
awkward clumsy unnecessary back and
forth between the vikings and zack
hiller i'm concerned that that this
accidentally ends up in a confrontation
that can be avoided we'll see how that
plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports